- Hey, it's Akilah,
and I'm with Comedy Central,
at South by Southwest.
We're talkin' to some comedians
about the things you wanna know.
What would your app
do if you had one?
- I'm trying to work on an app
that makes me have a
better personality.
- It would hold
all text messages
that you send after midnight.
- It's just like a person
that's looking out for you.
- Maybe a rare cello finder,
so if you're in your town like,
"Where am I going to find some
really fucking rare cellos?"
Not regular
run-of-the-mill cellos.
- I would make an app for Chris
that every time he
gets offered a job
and he writes back yes,
it intervenes and
blocks the email.
- I feel like you
have a few jabs.
- Just a few.
- You have a new app.
- The theoretical
Chris cyber app.
What does it do?
- I would just erase
all the negativity
on the internet.
- Oh my god!
- I'm gonna have
to invent the app.
I'm gonna get so fucking
trolled for that.
- It's so real.
- Yeah, I know,
it's so real.
- Damn.
- But hey, South by Southwest.
- Thank you for being here.
Yeah!
- Yes!
We did it!